The First Man to Walk in Space Almost Got
Stuck Out There
That lucky individual was Alexei Leonov, who
was born in the Soviet Union on May 30, 1934.
He was one of the twenty Soviet Air Force
Pilots to be chosen for the first cosmonaut
group.
Originally, his historic walk was supposed
to have happened on the Vostok 11 mission,
but as that was cancelled; it was later performed
on the Voskhod 2 mission instead.
After eighteen long months of training for
the event, Leonov was ready to become the
first person to walk in space.
The Voskhod 2 launched on March 18, 1965.
In addition to Leonov, Pavel Belyayev was
on board to man the ship while Leonov attempted
the space walk.
It was the first trip into space for both
of the crew members.
Once in orbit, Leonov strapped on an EVA (extra-vehicular
activity) backpack to his spacesuit.
It provided him with just 45 minutes of oxygen,
which would allow him to breathe and keep
cool; meanwhile, heat, moisture, and carbon
dioxide would be vented into space via a relief
valve.
VoskhodBelyayev pressurized the inflatable
airlock, which took seven minutes to fully
inflate.
Everything went smoothly at first and Leonov
spent a total of 12 minutes and 9 seconds
out on his space walk.
He described the experience by saying he felt
“like a seagull with its wings outstretched,
soaring high above the Earth.”
Unfortunately, all good things must come to
an end, and he needed to get back inside the
spacecraft before he ran out of air.
But getting back inside proved to be a problem.
He maneuvered himself back to the airlock,
but then realized that his suit had become
incredibly stiff.
Due to the lack of atmospheric pressure, it
had bloated with oxygen.
His feet and hands had pulled away from his
boots and gloves, and he knew it was going
to be incredibly difficult to get himself
back into the ship safely.
There was only one way to do it: wriggle in
head-first while bleeding off the oxygen in
his suit.
I knew I might be risking oxygen starvation,
but I had no choice.
If I did not reenter the craft, within the
next 40 minutes my life support would be spent
anyway.
Leonov thought about contacting mission control
about his predicament and let them know about
the risky thing he was about to do, but decided
not to.
He knew that he was the only one who could
do anything about the situation and he didn’t
want to worry the people on the ground.
As he released oxygen and exerted himself,
his suit began to heat up dangerously with
his core body temperature rising 3.2 degrees
Fahrenheit (1.8 degrees Celsius), as he slowly
clambered into the airlock inch by inch.
Once he was finally in, he had to let even
more air out so he could curl his body around
to close the hatch, which he eventually accomplished.
At last with the hatch sealed, Belyayev was
able to pressurize the airlock again and Leonov
made it back inside the spacecraft after the
heart-stopping few minutes of struggle.
On the ground, people had watched the very
first spacewalk, though Leonov’s struggle
to get back inside the spacecraft wasn’t
televised.
At the first sign of trouble, the transmissions
shown on televisions on Earth “randomly”
stopped with no explanation, with most assuming
technical difficulties with the broadcast
feed.
Leonov was thankful they didn’t show his
re-enty, “My family was therefore spared
the anxiety they would have had to endure
had they known how close I came to being stranded
in space.”
Unfortunately, this was only the start of
the problems.
Just five minutes before they were scheduled
to begin re-entry, the crewmen discovered
that the automatic guidance system wasn’t
functioning.
They would have to land the spacecraft manually
and were also dangerously low on fuel to maneuver
to boot.
To do the necessary maneuvers, Leonov stated:
Pasha began orienting the craft for reentry.
This was no easy task—in order to use the
optical device necessary for orientation,
he had to lean horizontally across both seats
in the spacecraft, while I held him steady
in front of the orientation porthole.
We then had to maneuver ourselves back into
the correct positions in our seats very rapidly
so that the spacecraft’s center of gravity
was correct during the reentry burn.
The difficulty of the landing was compounded
by politics.
They had to land on Soviet soil; if they overshot
and landed in China, which had very poor relations
with Soviet Russia at the time, a potential
international incident could have ensued.
They also had to choose somewhere without
many people.
Thus, Leonov chose Perm, a sparsely populated
area far from China.
It seemed like a safe bet.
However, additional problems started as they
entered the Earth’s atmosphere.
The craft began spinning uncontrollably.
Why?
The orbital module was still attached to the
landing module.
The modules hadn’t fully detached when they
were supposed to, due to a thick communication
cable connecting the two.
Not only did it throw the landing location
off significantly, but the two craft spun
around one another, subjecting the cosmonauts
to as high as 10 G’s of force.
So much, that Lenov said that the “small
blood vessels in our eyes burst”.
At around 62 miles high (100 km), the cable
burned up and they were able to stabilize
and land successfully… in two meters of
snow in Solikamsk on the outskirts of frigid
Siberia.
Upon attempting to open the hatch, they further
had difficulty after the explosive bolts blew.
Rather than the hatch opening, it was stuck
shut:
Looking out of the window, we could see the
hatch was jammed against a big birch tree.
We had no alternative but to start rocking
the hatch violently back and forth, trying
to shift it clear of the tree.
Then, using all his strength, Pasha managed
to push the hatch away from the remains of
the bolts, and it slid back and disappeared
into the snow.
At this point, Leonov and Belyayev’s families
were told that the two had landed safely and
were resting before returning to Moscow.
However, Soviet officials hadn’t picked
up on the rescue signal, and had little idea
where they’d landed or even if they were
still alive.
Lucky for the cosmonauts, a cargo plane did
pick up on the signal and the word of their
location spread around.
Initial attempts at rescue were made by civilian
aircraft, with helicopter pilots and others
throwing the two down supplies, including
wolf skin boots and cognac.
(Note: contrary to popular belief, drinking
alcohol in such a situation would make hypothermia
significantly more likely, rather than it
heating your body.)
In the end, they ultimately had to spend the
night in a place packed with wolves and bears
during mating season- when they’re most
aggressive- and where the temperature dropped
to -22 degrees Fahrenheit (-30 C) according
to Leonov.
They also had no way to re-seal the landing
module, so simply had to hunker down and endure
the night.
The temperature problem was compounded by
the fact that their suits had sweat sloshing
around up to their ankles, along with being
soaked through the inner layers.
We had to strip naked, take off our underwear,
and wring the moisture out of it.
We then had to pour out what liquid had accumulated
in our spacesuits.
We went on to separate the rigid part of the
suit from its softer lining—nine layers
of aluminum foil and a synthetic material
called dederone—and then put the softer
part of the suits back on over our underwear
and pull our boots and gloves back on.
The next day, a rescue crew arrived traveling
via skis, while another came a day later and
chopped down trees, making a log cabin and
a huge fire to keep the team and cosmonauts
warm.
They then all traveled nine kilometers by
ski to a clearing where a helicopter was waiting
for them.
Upon arriving in the town of Leninsk, they
had one last duty: to report on their mission.
Leonov said simply,
Provided with a special suit, man can survive
and work in open space.
Thank you for your attention.
He didn’t go into detail about his brush
with death.
It’s possible that he was told not to; details
of the harrowing mission weren’t released
until much later.